des investitures on va évidemment
préfère les 577 mais vous savez quel âge
auras du mal à vous répondre il ya
notamment une investiture qui fait débat
c'est celle de ta boîte à l'euro à
bosser vous avez des idées
pas que elle fait aussi débat au sein
des autres partis de gauche qui est vous
soutiennent a priori avec lesquels vous
allez conclure un accord ta boite je le
rappelle condamné pour injure non tu as
raison non ils ont engagé une année par
un non choix s'il était condamné pour
avoir insulté une policière
d'années il avait été condamné en
première instance et merci maman est-ce
que son investiture est ce que vous
soutenez son investiture oui bien sûr je
soutiens son investiture bien sûr je
soutiens son avis et jean luc mélenchon
juste quand eric zemmour s'est présenté
à la présidentielle il a dit qu'il était
opposé à ce que des personnes condamnées
pour incitation à la haine raciale
puisse se présenter en mairie c'est pas
ça veut dire que ce qui vaut pour eric
zemmour ça vaut
d'abord ça vaut pas pour uriner moore du
tout puisque voyez bien sûr les pattos
il explique que pétain a sauvé des juifs
et ça dérange pas grand monde quand même
hein au regard de la violence de ce
qu'ils racontent donc ta aboaf est un
militant des quartiers populaires un
journaliste indépendant qui joua appelle
un permis de faire sortir la sphère
benalla donc c'est pas n'importe qui t'a
abois mais pas que oui mais pas que mais
qu'est ce qu'on décide mais pas qu'eux
mais quoi mais il ya aussi des produits
dits mais non dit ce qu'il a dit qu est
ce qu il a dit continuer une policière
quand il traite une policière d'arabe de
service pour vous c'est pas un problème
mais bien sûr que ce ne sont pas des
mots polis et comme il faudrait les dire
c'est pas bien voilà d'accord mais avec
tout ce qu'on entend aujourd'hui sur les
plateaux télé je vous assure que c'est
pas ce qui me choque le plus quand on a
un président de la république est
capable de parler aux français en disant
qu'il ya ceux qui réussissent et ceux
qui ne sont rien ça c'est d'une violence
inouïe et voyez il n'est pas condamné
bon donc moi je je je ne dis pas que
tous les propos de ta aboaf jolie
partage c'est pas ça le sujet le sujet
c'est que je dis que si on veut
régénérer la politique si on veut
l'ouvrir si on veut que ce soit pas
toujours les mêmes profils qu'ils soient
en responsabilité qui représente le
peuple alors il faut qu'on ait la
capacité à nous ouvrir à des
personnalités comme ta aboaf qui a
encore une fois fait partie aussi de
cette génération qui ne mâche pas ses
mots en effet et qui est capable de
mener des batailles politiques fortes
contre le racisme parce que franchement
condamne et aboaf qui est un militant
antiraciste pour incitation à la haine
raciste quand même pas la même chose que
zemmour peut pas mettre tout ça sur le
même plan ça n'a pas de sens ou alors
vraiment on a perdu la tête comprenez
non je vous redis ce qu'elle a dit jean
luc mélenchon qui vous les moyens de
condamner contre comprenez comprenez que
comprenait la folie du truc c'est à dire
que eric zemmour condamné pour elle
insiste on voit bien le sujet c'est tout
c'est toute sa colonne vertébrale qui
propose un projet xénophobe taha bois
fait un militant antiraciste qui vient
des quartiers populaires alors on peut
dire ces mots là ce n'étaient pas les
bons mots qu'il fallait dire sur un
plateau de télé mais vous pouvez pas à
cause de ces trois mots expliqué que
alors qu'il est très jeune encore une
fois que c'est aussi un militant très
jeune qui ne mâche pas ses mots parce
qu'il a de la colère voilà c'est fait
attention à ce qu'on dit non mais c'est
pour ça que je pardonne et moi je vous
parle un peu gisements mais parce que
cette polémique elle commence vraiment
oui je trouve que on mélange tout voyez
ce que j'ai en mélange tout les choses
perte de leurs de leur sens profond en
fait
[Musique]